c'était le troisième homme de cette
élection françois bayrou promettent dès
cette semaine la création d'un nouveau
parti le mouvement démocrate en mesure
selon lui de présenter 577 candidats aux
élections législatives mais qui seront
ses candidats aujourd'hui le président
de l'udf semble bien isolé daniel
sportiello le deuxième tour
à peine achevée et l'udf pense déjà aux
législatives
le troisième tour des présidentielles
pour françois bayrou qui veut présenter
des députés dans la plupart des
circonscriptions sous le sigle mouvement
démocrate
fort de son score de 18 500 à la
présidentielle ils espèrent qu'une vague
orange viendra contrebalancer le pouvoir
de l'ump dans la nouvelle assemblée
nationale le dit à nicolas sarkozy le
pouvoir absolu
cela peut être un confort on peut
décider ce qu'on veut il n'y a personne
pour s'y opposer
mais cela c'est l'apparence il faute
équilibrer le pouvoir c'est cela l'enjeu
des élections législatives françois
bayrou annoncera jeudi à la mutualité la
création de son nouveau parti mais la
plupart des députés sortants seront
absents en désaccord avec la stratégie
l'ouverture au centre gauche de françois
bayrou
quelques-uns d'entre eux dont le
président est le fort parole du groupe
udf négocier déjà cet après midi au qg
de nicolas sarkozy leur ralliement à la
future majorité présidentielle -
clairement
je m'affiche comme je les dis déjà dans
la majorité présidentielle
j'ai envie que la france s'en sorte et
j'ai envie que nous soyons positifs et
constructifs
du coup les députés étaient bien rares
hier soir sur les plateaux de télévision
et au siège de l'udf
nous on ne rencontrait que le dernier
carré de fidèles à très court les sept
millions d'électeurs qui ont voté pour
françois bayrou ne se sont pas évaporés
en quinze jours je pense qu'ils sont
toujours là
il croit toujours en ce projet nouveau
en cette nouvelle voie que françois
bayrou a proposé
vous verrez que aux législatives même
s'il ya des triangulaires dans nombre de
circonscriptions
nous arrivons en tête j'en suis persuadé
il est vrai que selon un sondage csa
cisco pour france 3 les candidats
centristes sont crédités de 15 % au
premier tour mais pour avoir des élus
des accords de désistement avec l'un ou
l'autre camp seront indispensables mais
pour l'instant aucun accord n'est à
l'ordre du jour